el índice de precios al consumidor
acumulado hasta marzo subió en Estados
Unidos un 5% frente al 6% que subió en
febrero una cifra que marca el ritmo más
lento de inflación desde mayo del 2021
reducción del índice de precios al
consumidor que ha sido impulsada sobre
todo por la disminución de los precios
de la gasolina sin embargo el índice
central que apunta a tener una idea más
clara de las tendencias de los precios y
que además excluye Los costos de
alimentos y combustibles que suelen ser
muy volátiles reveló que hay un
incremento de precios de el cinco coma
seis por ciento con respecto al año
anterior la reserva Federal que es el
Banco Central y que tiene como meta
controlar la inflación a través de las
tasas de interés ha estado tratando de
controlar este aumento de precios
durante poco más de un año elevando las
tasas de interés a casi el 5% desde cero
en marzo del dos para desacelerar la
economía y bajar los costos en general
sin embargo hay muchos críticos que
dicen que esta rápida subida las tasas
de interés está teniendo graves efectos
en el desempleo porque pocas empresas
tienen acceso a deudas con intereses tan
costosos para financiar sus operaciones
y se ven obligadas a despedir personal